et dany dubé lui était un bébé en
floride pour ce premier match je lui ai
parlé il y à quelques minutes alors dany
dubé à tampa bay peut-être avant de
savoir si les canadiens peuvent ramener
la coupe stanley à montréal on peut
peut-être vous demandez la saison une
chance de le battre
ning de tampa bay absolument ça va être
une série très intéressant que s'il ya
des éléments quand même assez évident
qui nous saute aux yeux le brio de carey
price depuis le la pause olympique
également l'absence de ben bishop qui
tous les gardiens de but et l'italie
nationale s'est blessé contre les leafs
de toronto
avec trois matchs à faire dans la saison
alors lui ne sera pas au rendez vous
pour le début de cette série ce qui
pourrait donner un avantage aux
canadiens veulent prendre le contrôle
rapidement de la série et on sait
lorsqu'on n'a pas davantage la glace ce
qui est le cas du canadien on veut
certainement gagner une des deux
confrontations
donc qu'est-ce qui était surveillé ce
soir on a remarqué que lorsque les
canadiens marque le premier but en
général ça va plutôt bien pour la suite
du match c'est important le premier but
oui absolument
surtout lorsqu'on est sur la patinoire
adverse on veut absolument s'assurer de
garder la foule à distance que la foule
ne soit pas un élément qui favorise
cette cette énergie qu'on veut
développer du côté de l'équipe locale
diamal premier but prend toute son
importance l'efficacité en avantage
numérique et canadiennes 01 28 ils ont
pas marqué depuis le 25 mars contre les
sabres de buffalo l'ont que ça fait une
mèche et ça aussi c'est naturel qui
était le canadien donc le fait de
marquer un premier but en avantage
numérique pourrait également servir de
catalyseur ils n'ont pas marqué en
avantage numérique ça fait longtemps
effectivement mais le brio de van eyck
pacioretty et desharnais va très très
bien par ailleurs
ouais ils vont bien mais n'ont pas eu
beaucoup de succès contre cette
formation et n'ont pas marqué un seul
but en quatre matches en ce qui concerne
pacioretty et desharnais donc seul enjeu
pour eux le meilleur ça a été quand même
et ça c'est une surprise c'était daniel
brière qui a marqué deux buts il est le
seul joueur qui a réussi un doublé
contre cette formation long qui sera
définitivement parmi les joueurs cachés
du canadien une carte cachée et piqué
subban aussi autant en avantage
numérique à 55 doha devra se retrouver
christian c'est un joueur clé chez le
canadien de montréal et il devra
connaître une excellente série pour
permettre à son équipe de l'emporter
bon quelques erreurs les canadiens vont
devoir éviter le pour vaincre le
lightning passé sur deux équipes
extrêmement rapide
le match peut changer d'alluré très très
très vite
alors qu'est-ce qu'on ne doit pas faire
contre le lightning pour pour gagner
enfin
premier élément c'est pour relaxer
lightning très forte en contre attaque
donc on peut pas avoir de moments
d'inattention limiter le nombre des roms
et surtout et avant tout éviter de se
camper en défense et de jouer un style
de jeu trop conservateur trop axé
exclusivement unidimensionnel du range
axé sur la défensive
hélas ce moment-là ça permettrait aux
joueurs du lightning de carburer à cette
vitesse offensive qu'il possède il faut
vraiment être capable d'égaler cette
vitesse en défiant le lightning de tampa
bay et surtout profité des deuxièmes
chances de l'équipe du lightning
provoquée par un gardien de but
probablement inexpérimenté puisque
leanback sera devant le filet c'est un
gardien de but format géant six pieds et
six pouces c'est un gars très costaud
mais qui n'est pas très agile alors il
vaut faire le premier arrêt plus souvent
qu'autrement mais sur les retours de
lancers canadien de rock efficace je
pense que là ya un élément extrêmement
important pour la stratégie du tricolore
très rapidement en terminant dany je
sais j'aime beaucoup ça jouer sa joie ça
avec vous la petite prédiction peut-être
peut-être pas pour la coupe stanley mais
pour la série combien de matches là et
que je choisis le canadien j'ai choisi
le canadien entre 6 et la raison pour
laquelle j'ai choisi le canadien c'est
avant tout pour l'expérience des du
lightning de tampa bay et
particulièrement devant le filet
je pense que price aura
pour une première fois à tous les
budgets acariens un mot à dire important
sur la victoire de son équipe
alors vous savez ça c'est noté et puis
on s'en reparle après les séries merci
beaucoup d'années c'est ce qui
m'inquiète mature bras